it's an amazing feeling pressure all
signs point to the Beavers finally
walking down the aisle just months after
Justin and Haley Bieber tied the knot in
secret in a New York courthouse last
September eet's he has learned they're
seemingly gearing up for a more
traditional celebration I mean guys it's
about time I saw cells ET the newlyweds
text a save the day two close friends
family for an event in the next couple
of months
we're told the text provided little
information including no word of the
location because they want complete
privacy now it's still not 100% confirm
what kind of event mr. and mrs. Bieber
are throwing but here's what we know is
on their wedding wishlist
a source tells ET they want the music
entertainment and exciting details to be
a big surprise for their guests our
source says Justin may enlist his
personal DJ to spin on the ones and twos
assuming DJ Tate James now no word on
who got the invite but our predictions
are of course that their parents are
going to be there all the famous
Baldwin's in tow
Haley's besties Gigi Hadid Kendall
Jenner and Justine Skye and of course we
know they already had an intimate
ceremony so we have a feeling they are
going to go all out with a big
celebration with friends our insider is
calling it a party to be remembered now
one thing's for sure the lovebirds are
still on cloud nine our source adds
quote Justin and Haley are so happy and
inseparable they are thrilled that they
can finally share their love and
commitment with family and friends what
do you love about Justin Emily
you know he's really funny we have a
good time together he's just really
sweet he's a good kid
it's a good part and I love it does your
dad like him that's the big question
what was my parents like him a lot
you need that parental approval ferret
for old school and the feeling is mutual
with Justin's mom patty which we know
wasn't the case with all his exes I mean
he said it in all this music mom I don't
like you
she likes everyone on Tuesday she took
to Instagram with a cute selfie of her
and her daughter-in-law captioned what a
gift
hailey sweetly replied with love you in
the comments it's nice to see the two
most important ladies in Justin's life
getting along so well I mean guys we
have heard about in lost stories from
hell and this is not one of them and
it's good to have hailey back on social
media after a brief hiatus the model
told VOC Arabia she wanted to limit her
online time to drown out the public
opinions about her life and relationship
Haley got candid about her insecurities
and goal to be more confident in 2019 in
a lengthy Instagram post reading in part
quote every single day is a confidence
battle for me she added it's hard
finding who you are but what's even
harder is being picked apart and
compared to other women while trying to
do that there are days that I'm simply
broken because of it of course her hubby
had the best response at the comments
writing this is beautiful hon it also
sounds like that Bieber party is the one
to be at and we wish we had an invite of
course look if you updated on all the
latest so be sure to subscribe to all
things ET and until next time I'm at
Kourtney underscore teza know we've got
you covered
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]